welcome to who's there a show about
cloud identity
[Music]
in the last episode of who's there I
talked about why identity platform is
awesome
and how to enable it in your GCB project
today I'm showing you how to integrate
identity platform into your Android app
in Java if you haven't enabled identity
platform yet I recommend you check out
the last episode of who's there before
proceeding you also need an Android app
in Android studio start with an existing
app or create a new one and if Android
doesn't happen to be your jam check out
the getting started videos for iOS and
web both link below re with all the
prerequisites out of the way let's get
started in the cloud console for my
project I selected the identity platform
tab I previously add an email and
password authentication so if you
haven't yet click add a provider and
select email password there are lots of
other providers to explore but today I'm
just going to stick with this one on the
providers page you see a link in the
upper right for application setup
details this pops up a window with brief
getting started information when I click
the Android tab I see to get started
with Android you'll need to register it
and add firebase configuration to your
app learn more I click get started with
firebase which takes me to an entirely
new console some of the information is
the same as the cloud console like
project name and ID but then there are
all these new tabs down the side that
say develop quality analytics and grow
and a big pop up in the middle asking
about data sharing if you used firebase
before this probably looks familiar but
it's entirely possible you've never even
heard of firebase let alone used it so
let's talk about what's going on here
firebase is a suite of products to help
you build your app and grow your user
base it includes SDKs for Objective C
and Swift for iOS Java and contantly for
Android JavaScript for web as well as
several web frameworks like angular
there are game specific SDKs for unity
and C++ and so much more I can make a
whole series of videos just on firebase
but fortunately the firebase team has
already done
if you're interested in finding out more
check out the documentation in the
firebase YouTube channel both linked
below so in many ways firebase is the
perfect complement to Google cloud very
broadly speaking Google cloud products
focus on server-side solutions like App
Engine compute engine cloud functions
kubernetes Engine and cloud run and fire
based products focus on client-side
solutions like authentication cloud
messaging
cloud storage for firebase and so on and
I admit that it's challenging to pin
down the relationship between Google
cloud and firebase so if we're my
oversimplified explanation is that
firebase is a way to access some Google
cloud platform products from a client
application specifically for identity
platform
this explanation works well the firebase
authentication able you to access
identity platform functionality from
your client with that in mind let's head
back to that firebase console the
firebase console automatically opened to
our project notice this UI indicates
that QuickStart is already a firebase
project when adding identity platform
took a Google cloud project a firebase
project it's automatically created first
let's deal with this pop-up it's up to
you whether you want to check off to use
the default settings for Google
Analytics data or just to select do this
later some fire based products depend on
an analytics like a be testing so if you
decide to incorporate other features you
will probably want to enable this again
it's entirely up to you when you click
on the project settings notice that the
settings are identical to the cloud
QuickStart project firebase has
basically added some more details and
functionality to the cloud project
similar to when you enable an API or add
software from the marketplace since you
want to add identity platform to an
android app select add app Android this
gives you a window with a series of
steps to follow now keep in mind when
you pick the Android package name it
must match the package name of your
Android app the app nickname is totally
up to you you can leave it blank if you
prefer I don't provide the SHA
one certificate since I'm not using any
of the products for which it is required
but if you plan on implementing Google
sign-in or phone number sign in and off
feel free to add the sha-1 here before
creating an app you can also add it
later now you are prompted to download a
Google services JSON file this file
informs your Android app about the
firebase app so you can interface with
firebase products once downloaded add
this to your android project click Next
in the console and it gives you the next
step add the Gradle dependencies
required to use firebase in addition to
the Gradle files required to build
firebase app you also need specific
Gradle file to use firebase off add the
following project level and app level
dependencies you can see them here in
your app in Android studio declare an
instance of firebase off okay
now you can use the firebase off SDK to
sign up log in log out and get user info
about an identity platform user identity
platform gives you access to many
different login providers including
federated identity providers like Google
Facebook and Twitter
you can enable several login methods for
an app allowing your users to
authenticate the way that they prefer
some login methods may require
additional steps which are listed in the
console when you enable that login
method see the documentation below for
information on how to implement other
login providers for now let's get back
to implementing email and password login
in the cloud console create a fake user
with a test email and a test password of
course you can create a new user from
the client but this is a good way to get
your app up and running quickly see how
to create a user in your Android app
following the link below in onstart call
a function called login this function
calls the firebase off method sign in
with email and password passing the
email and password you created in the
cloud console when the
sign-in function completes the
uncomplete listener is called passing
the auth result task if the task is
successful then you are signed in I've
add a log and toast to reflect this
if the sign-in fails I display this as
well just for a reference right now so
it's clear that my example thus far is
not a complete aw solution you need a
way for users to create accounts handle
password resets and logout each of these
functions needs some UI development as
well if you prefer you can write all
this functionality yourself using the
firebase guides as reference but you
also have the option to use the firebase
author UI module this open source UI was
created by auth specialist at Google it
includes all the views you would need to
implement account creation login logout
and password reset functionality you can
incorporate auth UI in just a few lines
of code personally whenever I start a
new project I use firebase UI so I can
focus on the key features of my app
while still protecting data through
authentication but whether you make your
own UI or use firebase UI you will very
likely need to know the auth status
before performing any app actions for
example you want to check if there is a
user logged in before writing to a
database that's where getting the
current user comes into play let's look
at how to implement that functionality
to get the currently sign-in user call
get current user on your firebase off
instance you may have noticed that this
function was already called in the
unsuccess listener if the appearance of
your UI depends upon whether there is a
current user you can call gate current
user in on start I put the code to log
out in this separate function called log
out I'm going to call this function at
the end of the onsuccess listener if the
login was successful
of course it's unusual to log in only to
log out immediately but this is purely
for the sake of example so you can see
the logout function run okay I build and
run the app and the console logs show
that the user is logged in
and then logged out congratulations you
just added identity platform to an
Android app ready to see what else
identity platform can do check out the
firebase off Android guides auth
QuickStart code and firebase YouTube
channel and subscribe to the Google
cloud platform channel so you can be the
first to know about new videos in de
who's there series thanks for watching
and I'll see you on a future episode
[Music]
you
[Music]